cómo seleccionamos las unidades no lo
hacemos pinchándose una posibilidad
latente de que fallemos en cambio
realizamos un marco abarcando la unidad
que necesitemos seleccionar Si queremos
abarcar un número mayor Pero tenemos
unidades de diferentes tipos podemos
mantener apretado alt para que solo nos
seleccione las unidades económicas en
cambio para las unidades militares
mantenemos presionado control si ya
tenemos seleccionadas algunas unidades y
queremos Añadir más mantenemos apretado
shift si queremos específicamente de
militares mantenemos la tcla que ya
sabemos y en el caso de las económicas
alt má shift Porque si solo apretamos
alt nos renovará las
[Música]
seleccionadas